[Musique]
je vais interdire des téléphones à
partir de lundi voilà ce que vous aimez
pas l'amour simplement battu 1 28 to my
home maintenant il a téléphoné partout
parfois et ça c'est vrai je vous le jure
c'est le producteur qui envoie un texto
je peux vous le montrez ouais mais c'est
vrai ah ouais donc on les garde pas
parce qu'on vous permet de communiquer
avec la rive créateur s'est lui dit la
vérité non en régie du mordant temps se
soit pas l'argument non excusez moi non
arrêtons maintenant monsieur delorme au
jet danger ici une oreillette a relié à
la production qui vivent déjà envoyé au
cas texto tu sors voilà qu'en réflexion
je savais pas vous êtes sinon rien ou
que tu croirais n'arrive pas à faire les
missions sont le chef
quand il n'est pas là c'est moi alors ta
gueule
[Applaudissements]